this week we're talking about the
kubernetes product security committee
Java 11 for App Engine and gke uses
metering I'm Carter Morgan and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news when it comes to
open source software there's plenty of
work to be done that can be both
encouraging and terrifying depending on
your perspective if you're a company
considering kubernetes as the core of
your cloud strategy this recap of
security investigation should be a great
comfort to you and your CTO it's a great
breakdown of how vulnerable E's are
assessed investigated and resolved by
the product security Committee for
kubernetes speaking of resolving things
Java 11 for App Engine is now generally
available so if you've been dreaming of
building modern Java backends using
modern frameworks or simply using the
latest language features of Java 11 your
dreams have come true
also new this week more features in
bigquery we've added new scripting and
stored procedures multiple queries in a
single statement simplify the process
for migrating teradata to bigquery and
increase bi engine reservations these
updates bring even more flexibility
simplicity and choice to your data
warehouse as always google cloud is
designed to be flexible and this means
making sure your cloud uses fits your
needs to help out with this google
kubernetes engine wrote out usage
metering in beta earlier this year
it's now ready for anyone to use so you
can reduce waste thanks to consumption
based metrics that allow you to compare
and contrast resource requests with
actual utilization if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link and if you
have any thoughts or ideas leave us a
comment or tweet us I'm Carter Morgan
and we'll see you in the cloud
you